[Music]  oh life moves fast one day you're  playing Kick the Can with kids named  flick and Schwartz  the next thing you know you're a  certified adult  Ralph dear old man  he was the best  promise me we're gonna make this a  wonderful Christmas that would make your  father so happy I promise  what have I done and now it was all up  to me I suggest you start drinking and  don't stop till New Year's  kids who wants to go see Santa this is  amazing incredible we will meet you  right here when you're done don't let  him kick you in the face  when it's just us decorating it kind of  feels like child labor honey it's not  labor if we don't pay you  cheers  that doesn't mean it was easy  Schwartz I triple dog Daria oh I got it  now get ready  [Applause]  that's brutal It's the Most Wonderful  Time slowly I could feel the Christmas  Ember beginning to Glow again  [Music]